is unconstitutional to ban an entire
class of weapons one that the public
find most useful for self-defense hi I'm
Jim Cavanaugh a reason TV we're here
with Charles Nichols president of
California right to carry and a writer
in Redondo Beach he has recently filed
the first lawsuit against the state of
California which recently passed a ban
on open carry could you tell us a little
bit about open carry just for people who
might not know what we're talking about
discussing it's really quite simple when
you're gonna carry a handgun there is
really only two manners of carry you
either gonna carry it openly in a belt
holster or rifle or shotgun in his sling
or are you going to carry a handgun
concealed the situation that we had
prior to this new law which started at
the beginning of 2012 was the California
did allow open carry in the sense that
you could wear your gun openly but it
had to be unloaded it has always been
legal dopily carry a loaded handgun in
the state of california california night
to the 1967 law required that the
ammunition be kept separate from the
firearm and the new law says that even
if the weapon is unloaded you cannot
wear it on your home on your hip that is
correct
it applies two handguns applies to every
incorporated city you cannot carry a
handgun loaded or unloaded openly in
public in public places you have to
remember California is a very broad
definition of public place your front
yard is a public place in California
your backyard is a public place you
driveways a public place and that's it
it's completely enclosed my fence tall
enough to keep the public out can you
compare the the carry situation in
California what are you allowed and not
allowed to do in California as opposed
to how does it compare with other states
California it is kind of unique in that
we find ourselves once again in a 19th
century case for the state is banned
handgun
in my lawsuit we're gonna have the same
argument that was held in the California
Supreme Court in 1924 same argument that
was brought by genital symmetry argument
that was brought up in the Heller
decision in 2008 it is unconstitutional
to ban an entire class of weapons one
that the public find most useful for
self-defense California's ban the carry
of handguns not constitutional into
California or federal law what is the
nature of your challenge what are you
what's your suits say I'm seeking an
injunction against the law enacted in
1967 which made it a crime to openly
carry a loaded firearm in incorporating
cities if I were openly carrying a
loaded handgun or unloaded merely for
the purpose of self-defense never took
it out of the holster I would risk up to
a year in jail a thousand dollar fine
and if my handgun was not registered
with the dealer record of sale registry
it's a felony
so I'm seeking an injunction against
that 1967 law okay what does that have
to do what is the injunction you're
seeking have to do with the law that was
recently passed banning it would render
it irrelevant the California politician
who led the charge on the new law
Portantino horton t know it told us that
you this is really about if I'm going to
get a cup of coffee or a burger or
something and I see somebody with a gun
I'll be disturbed and and my right not
to be disturbed is important too
unfortunately for mr. Portantino who was
a former art director for a long time
ago for the television show Grizzly
Adams he really should have cracked open
a law book before he wrote this bill
aesthetics is not grounds to ban
anything even under what's known as
rational review I mean because you don't
like the look of something is not a a
basis to upholding a law is anyone
challenging this new law on that basis
I'm the only one who's challenging I'm
the only one who will challenge both the
National Rifle Association and the
Second Amendment Foundation are opposed
open-carry there are a handful of dates
particularly southern states five of
them some of the states would still have
their old slave code which being black
codes after the Civil War prohibiting
openly carried firearms there were four
efforts to repeal those laws in Florida
Arkansas Texas and Oklahoma in our area
post all of them killed every one of
them what's the logic that governs bans
or regulation of concealed carry and
open carry is is open carry considered
more of a threat to the public or
concealed carry under logically it would
seem like concealed carry would be more
of a threat because somebody could be
hiding a gun and you don't know it that
is the conclusion of the California
courts that concealed carry unlike open
carry presents a threat to public safety
because a person doesn't know if another
person is armed that's why they require
permits so the wonderful thing about my
the chances of my injunction being
successful because not only do I have
the Heller decision I have California
case law going all the way back to 1891
where the courts have said that open
carry is the lawful manner of carrying
this date and oh by the way you can't
ban handguns from being openly carried
and it is concealed carry which is the
public safety hazard not open carry what
is the name of your shoot where can
people find it it's Nicholls V Edmund G
Brown jr. itaú you go to the california
right-to-carry dot org website thanks
very much
Charles Nichols thank you thank you for
joining us a reason TV I'm Tim Cavanaugh